pour cet hiver rappeler qu'en fait on a
trois crises imbriquées d'une dans
l'autre on a une crise durablement de
l'approvisionnement en gaz qui est là
pour plusieurs années donc moi je mets
cet hiver dans un contexte plus général
une question de production nucléaire qui
est liée essentiellement à la corrosion
sous contrainte cette année mais dans un
système qui était déjà très tendu et une
crise de production hydraulique au cours
de cette année l'hydraulique c'est notre
deuxième source de production
d'électricité alors c'est vrai en France
c'est vrai aussi dans un certain nombre
d'autres pays il faut pas l'oublier
parce que ça a conduit à des situations
de tension qui sont qui sauraient alors
vous n'oubliez pas mais souvent on parle
toujours de nucléaire et jamais
d'hydraulique l'hydraulique c'est la
deuxième source c'est une énergie
renouvelable c'est un énorme potentiel
de flexibilité et donc nous pensons à
elle bon
quand on a publié l'analyse globale sur
cet hiver c'était en septembre il y
avait trois grands scénarios ce qu'on
peut dire déjà aujourd'hui c'est que
nous avons écarté le scénario le plus
contraint
celui du bas le scénario le scénario du
pire pourquoi quand on regarde les
grands les grandes
les grands paramètres la consommation
d'électricité on publie toutes les
semaines une évaluation de la
consommation tous les mardis soir qui
est retraités des des aléas
météorologiques donc c'est pas la
consommation brute et la consommation
retravaillée ramener à une température
normale au niveau de la France entière
sur les quatre dernières semaines elle
est en diminution de 9% et sur la
dernière semaine
9,7 donc c'est c'est tout à fait
considérable par rapport à la moyenne
2014 2019
et c'est pas uniquement un effet dans le
secteur de l'industrie c'est l'industrie
le tertiaire et le résidentiel donc là
aujourd'hui on a on a cette vision
complète c'est c'est très impressionnant
et et honnêtement ça n'était absolument
pas gagné vu du mois de septembre donc
il y a bien quelque chose qui s'est
passé pendant le secteur industriel il y
a une question d'activité économique et
de signal prix mais il y a aussi
beaucoup d'effets de sobriété qui sont
désormais visibles ça n'est plus du
disco ça n'est pas de la chimère voilà
ça l'effet il est très net et vu les
températures qu'on a qu'on a connues au
cours des derniers jours si on n'avait
pas eu cette baisse de la consommation
la situation aurait été tout autre sur
le nucléaire on est revenu sur notre
cours de septembre de prévisions de
septembre moi je vous rappelle qu'on
avait
la situation je dirais je veux pas dire
confortable mais qui souhaitable pour
passer l'hiver c'était 40 gigawatts au
premier décembre et 45 début janvier
là on a le président Raymond là on a
parlé plus de 41 gigawatts de
disponibilité du parc nucléaire une
production du parc nucléaire donc on est
même légèrement au dessus de la courbe
bon c'est c'est très en dessous des
minimums mais vu la situation dans
laquelle on était c'est très
satisfaisant moi je remercie tous les
gens qui se sont mobilisés pour les
activités de maintenance
de et qui ont fait en sorte qu'on arrive
à ce niveau là parce que
on est dans une situation aujourd'hui il
y a une stratégie de le défaut identifié
on sait monsieur deauduc en parlerait
mieux que moi mais on sait quelles sont
les réacteurs qui sont qui sont
susceptibles d'être concernés
il y a eu des protocoles qui ont été mis
en œuvre je trouve qu'il y a beaucoup
moins d'incertitudes que lorsque que au
printemps et elle était et donc moi je
trouve que la situation est bien plus
favorable donc
on est on a vraiment et on est vraiment
pas du tout dans le bas du faisceau qui
pouvait être qui pouvait être craint au
début du mois de septembre sur
l'hydraulique alors là on a remonté on
est on était on est sorti des thés avec
un niveau de stock hydraulique
catastrophique et la gestion prudente
qu'on a eu au cours de cette période là
fait qu'aujourd'hui les stocks sont
revenus dans la dans les moyennes
historiques et que on a bien vu ces
derniers jours que on les pouvait les
utiliser donc ça c'est très satisfaisant
et puis un dernier point qui fonctionne
très bien ce sont les interconnexions
européenne alors là c'est extrêmement
fluide et
plus je dirais que souvent il y a des
gens nous ont posé la question mais
alors est-ce que les autres pays vont
nous envoyer l'électricité déjà je
rappelle que en fait ce sont pas les
pays qui s'échangent d'électricité
ce sont ce sont les fournisseurs les
producteurs qui s'échangent qui qui
s'achètent de l'électricité les uns les
autres
lundi dernier donc il y a deux jours du
froid on était en train d'exporter vers
le Royaume-Uni le Royaume-Uni était dans
une situation physique économique qui
nécessitait plus d'électricité que la
France le système a objectivement
extrêmement bien fonctionné au cours de
manière très fluide on avait pris des
prudence par rapport aux interconnexions
on en prend toujours ça fonctionne
au-delà des prudences qu'on a prises
pour le moment
et donc ça fait que la France peut
s'appuyer sur ce système voilà donc une
fois qu'on dit tout ça on est dans une
situation qui reste une situation de
grande vigilance on va on l'a dit et on
va pas le on va pas sortir de cette
situation là pour autant
une période qui était très risquée était
la fin du mois de novembre on l'avait
dit pourquoi à la fin du mois de
novembre parce que c'était le moment où
l'écart finalement ta disponibilité
nucléaire et
réel projeté la disponibilité x le
nucléaire historique était vraiment très
important cette période est derrière
nous il reste le mois de janvier sur
lequel on a dit qu'on avait une
vigilance particulière mais c'est le cas
tous les ans chaque année c'est toujours
le mois de janvier qu'on regarde de
manière de manière prédominante et en
matière de risque je tiens quand même à
dire que nous avons certainement les
moyens d'éviter des coupures si jamais
on continue avec les taux actuels
d'économie d'énergie qui sont qui sont
qui sont constatés et qui sont
réellement qui sont réellement tout à
fait significatifs en quelques mois et
s'il y a des Mobilis de mobilisation
particulière lors des signaux Ecowatt
lorsqu'on a développé ce dispositif ça
n'est pas pour dire que
améliora forcément une coupure c'est
pour dire que si jamais il y a une
réaction particulière lors de ces
signaux notamment des signaux rouges et
bien nous avons la faculté d'éviter les
délaissage et ça reste aujourd'hui notre
message on a l'impression que les
derniers jours nous ont montré que la
réaction des Français était
particulièrement à la hauteur de cette
situation